know the news you get when you first
wake up in the morning it can set the
mood of the entire day for example I get
on Twitter and everyone is letting me
know that there's a new Star Wars
trailer out today that sets a mood this
new trailer for Star Wars The Force
awakens it's still a teaser trailer two
minutes long doesn't give me anything
about the plot but does give you more
visuals to go on it starts out with the
four song
I can't sing for [ __ ] so that's the best
you get but it shows this landscape
attached wait just someone on one of
those little speeder bikes I think it's
the girl in the movie who on the first
teaser trailer she was on that speeder
bike there it shows this wrecked x-wing
fighter in this huge wrecked Star
Destroyer I noticed that about Abrams
movie this in Star Trek also where
things are so big and far away that
they're hazy just how it is you see a
mountain or something your look is so
far away it looks cloudy that's how it
looked it looks so cool that looks so
big I just immediately having that song
out the gate man it just puts me in Star
Wars mood I got my old curtain and a
ward as a cape I'm gonna do right now
feel the power in the curtain I'm gonna
keep this up for the video so if that
pisses you off yeah I'm a grown-ass man
I even have a beard right now and I'm
wearing a Star Wars curtain as a cape no
that's not at least kind of weird own it
see here Luke's voice over and he's like
the force is strong in my family my
father had it it shows the burned Darth
Vader helmet I have it shows his new
hand uses a new robotic hand he puts on
r2d2 is a little dome head my sister has
it
and you have that power too I was like
wha wait he's talking about family and
people with the force oh is it his kid
is it his kid is it Han and Leia's kids
things getting undone you cannot have
your Jedi cape get undone folks because
that's just the force does not awaken
you see that Darth Revan looking [ __ ]
with this crazy hilted lightsaber I know
nothing about this guys stay out of
spoilers I don't want to know anything
about this movie before going in I'll
know what the trailer shows me given the
concept that the trailers don't spoil
anything
looking at you terminator genisys
trailer there's just some cool imagery
some fighting some explosions john
boyega's running with the girls they're
like storm trooper and the guys that's
what I think is that she's like hey come
with me if you want to live he's like
all right yeah screw the Empire Bay he
says screw the Empire because this is
one scene where there's a TIE fighter
it's just wreck and Imperial dude it
could be one of a couple things one the
rebels are doing it to the Empire's
doing it three the Empire is doing it
making it look like the rebels are doing
it I think John boyega is a stormtrooper
who ultimately learns about the Empire
news series that's the fun thing about
trailers yeah all of it just could be
nonsense but it's fun to wear your Star
Wars curtain as a cape or TOC Star Wars
but you notice the camerawork he's just
different than what George Lucas turned
out it just it's more exciting it's more
organic it gives us the word it's more
real there on sets it looks like these
ship fights are dirty and then the
trailer just straight-up cheats the last
shot is Han and Chewie and Hans like
Chewie
we're home and she was all I was like
that is not fair dude it's like it
reminded me of a husband who's gonna
break some news to his wife so he gives
her chocolates and a ring on Valentine's
Day before he does it I just say there's
any bad news in it but ultimately that
is just cheating it's playing on Ferrier
playing into the emotions this trailer
starts out with the slow Star Wars Force
theme and it ends with Hans saying
Chewie we're home yeah I'm in cuz holy
[ __ ] it's Star Wars and it's just bits
back can you look at the comment section
of this trailer and the gripes are as
such I don't like the stormtrooper
helmets the font on the force awakens is
not that good I thought it would be
better [ __ ] like that if these are the
gripes you have you are reaching - not
like this so the force awakens trailer
there are well put together teaser
trailers these are how you should do
teaser trailers does that fanservice
[ __ ] yeah it has fanservice I'm a fan so
I am service they just makes me want to
be a grown-ass adult man wearing a Star
Wars curtain as a cape on a video for
thousands of people to say I want to
know what you guys think about it saw
the new Star Wars The Force awakens
teaser trailer - have you seen it what
did you think about it you wear your
Star Wars curtains as a cape now you did
wear it with pride
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
alright I guess I got a punch it